foreign
we have so far said that kovid has
diagnosed the journalist system that it
apparently there is no journalistic
system because we have giant stories
that in the in a past era would have
been an obsession of journalists that
are almost untouched
um we have said that the scientific
system is broken we are apparently
living in a dark age and even the basic
fundamentals of how science is done are
not being followed
the universities which were once these
truth-seeking establishments that were
independent and they were supposed to
follow the truth wherever it led have
become uh Protectors of particular
articles of faith of one team and not
the other
and then the next level which we haven't
talked about yet is that the U.S
government is apparently
completely captured and
it is captured at Best by private
interests that are at best indifferent
to the suffering and death of average
citizens right and I say it best because
there are far worse possibilities about
what they're up to but the indifference
or who they are that they display to the
harm done to the public and the
murkiness of whose interest it is that
they are serving is mind-boggling right
and covid made it so clear we watched
the entire system fail and not once not
20 times we saw a hundred different
failures that all looked alike right
they started them in real time and yet
seeming to be in slow motion
all you had to do was be mentally
independent in order to watch the system
predictably follow a particular
narrative irrespective of what evidence
loomed up in front of it right that was
an amazing fact right and and it took
over everything so all right you had a
government which I'm certain was never
free of corruption
but
at one time it functioned to a large
extent in the interests of the American
people and we watched covid reveal that
it's not in that business anymore no
percentage of it no percentage of it is
interested in the well-being of the
American people right that is a uh and
and uh
inconvenient obstacle that has to be
addressed only in as much as elections
require it to be addressed
right and to the extent that it can be
done entirely at a narrative level so no
actual uh bending of policy to the
citizenry has to occur all the better
from the point of view of whatever it is
that's captured our governmental
structure and whatever purpose it's on
about I really don't think we know but
we can see it isn't about us right
that's just simply where we are and then
the last one of these that I think covet
has diagnosed and you know maybe our our
listeners and our Watchers will find
others that I haven't spotted
is that covid revealed that National
sovereignty
barely exists anymore
right the degree of coordination of the
corruption over National borders yes
there were differences but the basic
point is something is in power across
the west and it
it got almost every nation to march in
lockstep
uh
in
complete indifference to the
countervailing evidence that says that
at least if if it were true
that the system were in fact confused
right if this had been some massive
error where people who thought they
understood things better than they did
had screwed up right there would have
been a wide diversity of approaches
across the west and we didn't see that
right we saw the occasional departure to
an extent right but we did not see
a wide diversity of approaches we saw
people doubling down on the same things
that turned out to be that started out
clearly wrong and became wronger over
time and yet the the policy remained
consistent as if that evidence had never
arrived I did want to point out the
exceptions that I that I know sure which
you know you you made a point of saying
uh that they were minor and I think in
the west that is true I think you know
Sweden actually in in early mid-2020 was
shocking to most of the rest of the West
because you know Sweden being in
Scandinavia is just the darling of of uh
liberals at least in terms of policy and
somehow somehow what that has come to
mean is surely they will lead the charge
in lockstep or something right like and
yet from the beginning they did not you
know they they took precautions
um but they did not close down schools
the same degree or impose masking or and
I don't think um ever ever went to
mandates vaccine mandates so Sweden was
a bit of an exception
in the west and in the west largely
there there were not many
but the rest of the world
the version that we hear
is
oh what needs to happen is this is about
inequity in vaccine access right and
what we need to do is make sure that all
of the poor people who I can't believe
we did this but they didn't get
vaccinated when the rest of the when the
West got vaccinated so what we really
need to do is basically cover cover
Africa with covert vaccines
so Africa most African most sub-Saharan
African countries with I imagine the
exception of South Africa and maybe a
couple of others
um is far less code vaccinated than
other other than countries in the west
and uh they were doing better right yeah
and similarly Latin America several
countries in Latin America struck out to
some degree on their own and for
instance started started actually
engaging in allowing people to partake
of early treatment of non
um you know off
off-label drugs which we've talked about
here before and uh did not suggest that
for the first time in all of human
history there was one and only one way
to treat this disease oh and by the way
the fact that it is neither effective
nor particularly safe should not stop
you
so it does feel like this is a disease
of the West unfortunately and there were
some there were some deviations but they
weren't gigantic whereas the deviations
to the degree that they exist were
largely chalked up in the west to more
Dei crap right this is this is more
about diversity inclusion and aren't we
all really racism that's why we haven't
given them all their shots
which is you know it's just layer upon
layer of garbage thinking right it's
that's the thing is the garbage thinking
now that we can stand back and say two
and a half years down what have we
learned about our system not what have
we learned about covet what have we
learned about our system because of
coven yeah one of the things that we
have learned and this is really the
point of this particular exploration
is we have learned
it is impossible for something like
covid to happen and for you not to learn
painfully what you didn't understand as
a result of what is revealed right you
discover your arrogance right you
thought this thing was going to work
very well you deploy this thing and you
discover ah it didn't do what I thought
and what's more I did this other thing I
didn't anticipate
it is impossible for that not to happen
in a system that is actually interested
in doing better right and the fact that
our system is not obsessed with
discovering what has now been revealed
by you know our attempts to to solve
this problem is the real thing that we
need to be alarmed by right that's
that's what I'm getting at is
now
in September of 2022
it is becoming apparent that the thing
doesn't care that it was wrong
um and what's the evidence for that well
for example
you have a
extremely unambiguous excess death
uh rate that appears to track our remedy
and our prophylaxis rather than the
disease itself there's some excess death
that is the result of Covenant but there
is a signal what do you mean by the
remedy and the prophylaxis well
The Way We have dealt with people who
are sick with covid and the way we have
attempted to prevent people from coming
down with coven right that's some sort
of medical policy
the
excess death signal
appears to track that and in particular
it appears to track the
so-called vaccines really transfection
agents but the so-called vaccines
rather than the disease itself there's
certainly an excess death signal from
covid but the distinction between the
pre uh inoculation phase of the pandemic
and the mid inoculation phase is
substantial now
a normal system
let's say that all of the people who
orchestrated policy had just been
arrogant boobs
right and they did the thing that we've
seen a thousand times where they thought
they understood the biology better and
they deployed a policy that seemed right
to them and you can imagine them talking
themselves into that belief into
certainty into certainty and then
deploying the thing and having nature
reveal their folly
well the natural thing that would follow
that I'm not saying this is good but the
natural thing that would follow that is
there would be a rush to shunt blame to
others there would be
a
and this is key there would be a rapid
campaign to reduce the future harm right
and that is not necessarily about
anything Noble it is just simply about
trying not to be responsible for more
suffering and death but you would not
for instance continue to see Mass PR
campaigns to vaccinate and boost your
children
right this this is the most obvious of
these things is if you were confused
about this then your confusion would
persist longest when it comes to the
people most jeopardized
by coven and your confusion would be
alleviated most rapidly with people who
were least jeopardized by covid and as
it turns out most jeopardized by the
supposed treatment exactly right so we
would expect the system to be
embarrassed into functioning and it is
not being embarrassed into functioning
it is doubling down on the same insanity
and it is basically going to take that
excess excess death signal and instead
of causing it to be finite in time it is
going to make it into a The New Normal
of the rate of death now
the problem
the many problems that are Downstream of
this recognition is
if it is indifferent to human suffering
and death now
after these patterns have been revealed
was it at first
right is this a new indifference it
thought it was right and then it decided
it didn't care that's unlikely I mean
even Occam's razors wise that's two
steps
the rational thing the most rational
thing the most parsimonious thing is to
imagine actually never you never gave a
[ __ ] in the first place maybe it wasn't
trying to be right right and that's
disturbing I don't like saying that out
loud I would love to believe that we
live in a system in which people who are
truly indifferent to the suffering and
death of others are relatively rare
right that most people care somewhat
some people care a lot but I would
imagine in general that indifference is
rare that it shouldn't be common even in
the halls of power
right it should be a rare thing and the
fact that it seems to be dominant in the
uh particular places in the system that
governed policy over the last two and a
half years
ought to alarm us and it ought to force
us to engage
certain kinds of questions but then this
goes back to where I started
which is
engage these questions with what exactly
we don't have the tools of science with
the tools journalism and other things
you would learn in college right you
would expect the university system to go
into high gear figuring out how these
errors were made what should have been
done what we ought to do now right you
would expect journalism
to be obsessed with uh diagramming the
failure figuring out who actually was
responsible right none of this is
happening and
really I don't you know Dark Age I think
is a good metaphor because
the hazard of living in a dark age isn't
about being in the scientific dark it's
about all the things Downstream of not
being able to figure out which way is up
right we are stuck
in a predicament where we have a lot of
things well maybe government should fix
this cool except that the thing that is
dressed as government isn't functioning
like a government right maybe University
should figure out what's happened Yes
except that that thing is now a church
that is hell-bent on not figuring out
what happened maybe some journalists
ought to look into it yeah except who do
they work for they can't work for any
major publication so they've got to be
an independent journalist and if they do
go after it maybe that's the end of
their career
I
[Music]